>> Sean: AND BREAKING NEWS
ACCORDING TO THE AP, JOE BIDEN
HAS NARROWED HIS VP SEARCH TO
SIX CONTENDERS.
THE SHORT LIST WOULD INCLUDE A
PARMA REP VAL DENNING,
ELIZABETH WARREN, SUSAN RICE,
THE ATLANTA MAYOR AND BY THE
WAY, KAMALA HARRIS, THE MEXICO
GOVERNOR MICHELLE THE,
CHRISTENED BY THE WAY.
THE LIST LEAVES OFF SOME MENTION
NAMES LIKE STACY ABRAMS,
MICHIGAN GOVERNOR, BUT THE LIST
IS APPARENTLY FLUID.
ACCORDING TO THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN,
WE NOW HAVE TO ON THIS PROGRAM
INTRODUCE A NEW RECURRING
SEGMENT.
JUST TRY TO KEEP UP, IT WON’T BE
EASY.
IT WILL FEATURE IN FEATURE THE
BIDEN BLUNDERS OF THE WEEK.
>> HAVE YOU EVER CONSIDERED WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF THE ELECTION
RESULT CAME UP AS A WINNER?
>> LET’S I YES I HAVE AND I WAS
SO PROUD.
YOU HAVE FOUR CHIEFS OF STAFF
COMING OUT AND RIPPING THE SKIN
OFF OF TRUMP.
>> Sean: A MILITARY WILL
ESCORT HIM OUT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
TERRY McAULIFFE SAID, I’M FINE
WITH HIM IN THE BASEMENT.
HE SEES TWO PEOPLE IN DAYS, BY
THE PEOPLE.
>> HE SIGNED IN THE BASEMENT.
TWO PEOPLE SEE HIM PER DAY, AND
THAT IS THAT.
LET TRUMP KEEP DOING WHAT TRUMP
IS DOING, IT’S HARD FOR THE
VICE PRESIDENT TO BREAK THROUGH.
>> I’M FINE, LEAVING IN THE
BASEMENT.
THE PRESIDENT HAVE A POINTED
RESPONSE, TO THE EVER FORGETFUL
JOE BIDEN CLAIMS THAT THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO STEAL THE
ELECTION.
THE NEXT WITCH HUNT IS ON ITS
WAY AND WOULDN’T LEAVE THE
WHITE HOUSE IF HE WAS DEFEATED.
>> JOE IS NOT ALL THERE AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
IT’S SAD WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT AND
YOU SEE IT FOR YOURSELF.
HE DOESN’T COME OUT, DOING
THINGS FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: SAID.
HERE’S BIDEN’S BLUNDER.
>> THE FAILURE TO RESPOND TO THE
PANDEMIC, I THINK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ADVOCATED ANY
EFFECTIVE LEADERSHIP ROLE, THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS ADVOCATED THAT
ROLE.
YOU KNOW THE RAPIDLY RISING
WITH, I DON’T KNOW.
HE IS INABILITY TO FOCUS ON ANY